this movie exists 26 seconds of snow
goes man can this beginning be anymore
Harry Potter over three and a half
minutes of confection Concepcion opening
credits if I wanted to know how
chocolate was born I'd take a trip to
Hershey Pennsylvania this is a story an
ordinary boy named Charlie Bucket Walker
a ship this Charles Dickens meets dr.
Seuss house appears to be rundown except
it was obviously built this way so
there's no way this door exists if it's
not specifically designed to go into
this door frame evening buckets evening
movie pays homage to the original film's
four-person bed an awesome image but
entirely impractical where to Grandpa
Joe and Grandpa George even put their
legs and do we even want to know I saw
one with my own two eyes I used to work
for him you know you did Charlie's been
building this exact scale replica of the
fucking Chocolate Factory for who knows
how long
but grandpa never brought up that he
worked there until now Willy Wonka began
with a single store in Cherry Street
grant position I'm gonna guess that
Wonka somehow bypassed the FDA when
concocting his candy stores in that
illicit genius if he can do that we've
seen so far the door at grandpa Joe is
looking for his wizard or based on the
way Depp plays the character possibly
easy I'm with Charlie
while we grab a Joe here that part of
the story I don't think getting riled up
in the four-poster was a good idea but
mr. Wonka was right of course
soon after this that came a very hot day
with a boiling Sun so Prince Pondicherry
thought this wouldn't happen were there
no hot days while Wonka was making the
palace and how did this conversation of
whether or not the prince intended to
eat or live in the palace not come up in
the whole time it was being worked on
they began sending in spies to steal the
secret recipes I'm not the most
up-to-date on my sweet treat spy craft
but in general wouldn't you rendezvous
somewhere slightly further away from the
very Chocolate Factory you were spying
on think abou bus started making
nice cream that would never melt so we
but not melting ice cream was actually
invented and sold and Grandpa Joe
shouldn't be talking about it as if it's
some big revelation he's running the
machines
nobody knows Johnny certainly it's a
mystery not as big of a mystery is how
no one ever fucking told Charlie any of
these stories before I'd give anything
in the world just to go in one more time
and see what's become of that amazing
factory rapido I was fortunate we so
hard right here he might start smelling
toast so they just eat and go to bed
no one gets bathroom breaks all four of
them are bed panning it I think is
impossible
jothee seen how a character suddenly
becomes lucid just in time to give
sobering words of encouragement cliche
also this all seems like strange
motivation for something that hasn't
even happened yet Charlie's family seems
to be creating this goal for Charlie to
get in Wonka's factory even before the
golden ticket news has been announced
indeed that very night Charlie died from
severe hypothermia from a gaping hole in
the roof mere inches from his bed
[Music]
I'd take a good danny elfman score as
much as the next guy
but sometimes I get the feeling he's
just been using variations on the men in
black school or for every movie since
1997 so dozens of people just happen to
be converging on this pole at the exact
same time are they all just there for
the every second Thursday telephone pole
snow orgy and happen to find this
message from Wonka dear people of the
world the world so did the delivery boys
ride those Vespas around the entire
world to post these notices in one night
what kind of santa's label does that
also where did that massive staff come
from they're not opelu us but Wonka
trusted them to deliver all these
notices and the chocolates with the
golden tickets even though he swore off
humanity years ago one of these children
shall receive a special prize beyond
anything you could ever imagine you're
giving them the factory right I think
you may be selling my imagination short
Wonka because I totally just pulled off
imagining that a candy bars may be
anywhere in any shot and in the streets
in any town in any country in the world
as long as the five winners can speak
English for the movies sake ha ha I get
it kids fat and loves chocolate but
you're telling me his mother wouldn't
clean the chocolate off his face before
he goes in front of the cameras yes man
suppose his daughter and no good ever
comes from spoiling a child like that
someone hasn't been keeping up with the
kardashians oh wait damn that was either
some quick math buy grab a Joe or he's
been creepily monitoring this total for
a while now what's the point of this
attention filled fake out reveal is
there a single human watching this movie
that doesn't know that bucket boy is
gonna eventually get a ticket
manufacturing dates offset by weather in
this room
I and I'll give you manufacturing dates
and weather but Nikkei index what does
the tokyo stock market have to do with
anything and regarding mike strategy the
bar with the ticket would still have to
randomly end up in denver right you
ungrateful didn't but jesus does mr.
buckets have beats by dre sound
canceling abilities in his hands Charlie
should still be able to hear at least
some of grandpa George's tapestry of
profanity Oh for the love of Roald Dahl
how many times we need to go through
this disappointment nonsense we spent
the first 30 minutes of this movie on
golden ticket fake outz
poverty born and being narrated at can
we get to some chocolate factoring
already charlie finds ten bucks in the
snow and his first thought is to buy a
third candy bar even after overhearing
that the last ticket was already found
no worries charlie
you've got a family of seven in a
one-room shack eating cabbage water for
every meal but you go right ahead and
buy some more chocolate this old puppet
carousel is the perfect metaphor for
this movie a fake plastic reproduction
that's annoyingly loud and garish and
ends up completely going down in flames
Tim Burton obviously decided the 1971
version of this story didn't have enough
nightmare fuel where exactly did Wonka
come from if the entrance to the factory
is right in front of them also wouldn't
there be at least a murmur from the
crowd behind the gate from seeing Wonka
for the first time in ages good morning
Starshine the earth says hello if you
listen closely with the right kind of
ears somewhere in the middle of that
line you can hear the exact moment the
world had had enough of Johnny Depp's
nonsense and the rest of you must be
their parents yeah mom Z dad's dad I
cannot begin to tell you how quickly and
forcefully I would remove children from
this man's presence would you like some
chocolate
then you should've bought something why
you're literally in a chocolate factory
pretty sure that was the one thing you
didn't need to bring also Moody is
deeply committed to us hating every
single character that isn't named bucket
I don't care how much you like good old
Charlie that it's a lot of asshole hurry
to sit through come with me try some of
my grits I am guessing there were many
involved in this head trip of a movie
that didn't heed try some of Wonka
scraps you need the cross of course you
can but would you want to they've been
walking all over that I understand they
had to make these kids unlikable but Tim
Burton went way over the top of this I
mean if you're gonna remake this why not
give these characters a tiny bit of
nuance instead of doubling down on the
asshole Atun Oompa Loompas imported
direct from the label would walk I've
done if he didn't happen upon a sudden
and conveniently subservient workforce
he'd already fired his entire staff
right he wants us to believe that as
fastidious and I don't know whatever's
going on with Willy Wonka he travel
through King jungle earning Swaddlers
and snozzwangers and those terrible
wicked Wang doodles
what are the names for my penis I'll
take over actor's name Johnny for 500
hours sword swallowing I went to
loompaland looking for exotic new
flavors instead I found the in balloons
and I totally wouldn't have believed
that these new balloons existed if I
didn't have this completely necessary
back story I'm more willing to buy that
won't Killearn the looper language and
could communicate with them than being
able to acquire all the passports and
documentation it would take to get them
back to his factory hey little boy Mike
must be touched by human hands that
doesn't seem like a great marketing
strategy also why the hell didn't want
to tell them that from the beginning
there was one rule
[Music]
why don't all the Oompa Loompas look the
same why are they miniature humans where
did they find their love for musical
theater why are they wearing full-body
latex uniforms and why do they rate
songs like a fifth grader trying to
figure out what rhymes with poop look
movie you're the one that wanted to give
the backstory for these guys so now I
need to know if I know my high school
physics and then I probably don't when
you have an overweight child object
stuck in your vacuum isn't the pressure
above the blockage not below so why
would it be spraying out like this all
the way down here so did the song and
dance number fix the situation because
the open-loop is otherwise did Jack I
didn't say that don't even bother at
Hearst they knew it was gonna happen as
if we needed more reasons to hate them
these snozzwangers would be excellent at
cinemasins I want you to take mrs. gloop
up to the fudge room okay is it just me
or does taking mrs. gloop up to the
fudge room sound like a new euphemism
for hitting the restroom Wong Kanta
forever on with the tour they're still
going on the tour after all the augustus
Gloop went down these people deserve
what ever saw like torture device falls
on their heads human hands can't touch
the chocolate the bottom of the boat is
fine as we're told several times the
waterfall churning is what makes the
chocolate unique so this is definitely
introducing an unnecessary variable
[Music]
God why does everything in this movie
taper effort to happen look one percent
of Tim Burton's imagination would kick
the shit out of the rest of the world in
an imagination battle but this seems a
little overboard even for him
sure Wonka would have an extravagant
boat but wouldn't he pick something to
fit better with the theme that's a
dragon have to do with any of this
llus antagonists and oppose 2000 rehash
gets an origin story even though it
doesn't need one and no one asked for
one cliche also it's completely
counterintuitive that this movie is
called Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
when it's much more wok eccentric than
the first one I know it supposed to be a
more faithful adaptation of the book but
you know how many feel about that around
here caramels they'd get stuck in your
braces wouldn't they oh man I had a drag
poor Christopher Lee into this didn't
think also of course Willy Wonka's dad
was a dentist who never let him have
candy long casts backstory was
apparently written by Admiral obvious
also also why the fuck Count Dooku saw
him on Willy go out trick-or-treating in
the first place if your candy burns like
this and I hate to be the one to tell
you this either you've got some bad
candy or you're in a Tim Burton movie
[Music]
and we can add animal cruelty for the
sake of a visual pond to the growing
list of reasons this Factory would have
been shut down ages ago
these are everlasting gobstoppers you
can suck on it all year and it'll never
get any smaller also known as the
everlasting choke hazard I'd rather you
didn't there's still one or two things
that are of them oh come on
Wonka we all know what you're up to you
put a stick of chewing-gum right in
front of the chewing gum champion this
whole thing is a big batch of entrapment
mixed with a heaping helping of child
endangerment and you're enjoying every
second of it that is one stretchy sweat
suit someone called Bruce banners
stylist because I think we found the
material for his next outfit
[Music]
I swear to the Greek Gobstopper in the
sky the music in this movie makes the
music in the lorax look like Hamilton by
comparison regardless of how exaggerated
her look is that's still violets body
the Oompa Loompas could be doing some
serious damage by jumping on it
we've gotta squeeze all that juice out
of her immediately given Wonka's look
and general demeanor I'm thinking this
environment is the only place where he
could say the sentence and not be
immediately arrested what's the special
prize you get Syd the best kind of prize
is a surprise ha ha ha ha the problem
with Johnny Depp's portrayal is that it
takes the beautiful beleaguered but
eccentric frustration of Gene Wilder's
Wonka and turns it into nothing more
than a case of a sociopath with severe
Arrested Development a take which steals
all the joy of Wonka finding someone to
finally take over the factory and
instead just makes us want to alert the
proper authorities oh I think that one's
kind of bad that's why we nicknamed him
Lance Luca little girl Jesus movies like
watching a slow speed car chase after
popping a couple valium it's always fun
to see a kid's movie turn into a street
horror film seriously bring on squirrel
spiria at least it would be interesting
sure most of these kids are awful but
these parents are worse they're
incapable and uninterested in helping
their kids out mr. salt can't jump over
the railing and run down the stairs to
save his daughter from some squirrels
for the sole purpose of this visual
guide Wonka was able to procure an over
large steak from Looney Tunes lion
ladies is it just me or does welcome to
fudge Mountain sound like a euphemism
for you know what maybe this whole movie
is a euphemism for taking a dump and
this is the puppet hospital and burn
center it's relatively new
come on movie you've already established
how weird Wonka is by the fact that he
has random flashbacks and likes to play
murder children this is just unfunny
overkill hi Doris so the only female in
bloom pose at the factory work in the
front office
I knew uncle was crazy but sexist too he
doesn't have to have a point that's why
it's candy nice try mr. Burton you're
not covering up all your nonsense of a
bull that easily your Ruby still has to
have an engaging story and voice as is
yet another flashback when we already
get the point looks like new line like
Christopher Lee keep those Saruman
powers for an extra year I don't figure
wrong
and even if we go by the assumption that
Wonka set all this up ahead of time
there are several things that still have
to fall into place
Augustus has to be left on his own and
start drinking out of and fall into the
river violet has to take the gum bait
which might be the easiest one but it
still has to go exactly as planned
Farooq asked to be interested enough in
the squirrels to go down and get herself
thrown down the chute and Mike has to
ask to pick a room it happens to be the
TV room and he has to get the idea to
transport himself wouldn't be easier to
just get them all in the factory have
them to sign who's the last man standing
like the joke we did in the dark night
incorrect inertia alert when this
elevator shoots forward everyone should
fall backwards not into the wall in
front of them cool you invented
teleportation and also apparently
levitation how is this Johnny Depp si go
sighs candy bar floating well why would
I want to send a person they don't taste
very good Oh
for those keeping track at home that is
the third cannibalism joke in this movie
all of which were the same basic
punchline and the same paucity of funny
oh no Mike I think mr. Wonka knows what
he's talking about really mr. TV you can
say that with a straight face harmed
what are you talking about little-known
fact Warner Brothers originally hired
Edgar Wright to direct the sequence but
in a different way due to creative
differences Johnny's the only one this
you mean you're the only one yes I don't
blame Wonka for not realizing this
because I sure don't forgot Carly was
part of this movie and we mustn't dilly
organic because we have an enormous
number of things to do before the days
out but luckily for us we have the great
glass elevator to speed things I wish
the creators of this movie had a glass
elevator then because this movie took so
little time and had so much that was
interesting
sorry strike all that reverse it it's
amazing to think that 12 years before
this Steven Spielberg made us believe
dinosaurs were walking on the earth but
Tim Burton can't make us believe that a
little girl is doing flips down some
stairs also it's great to get
confirmation that the kids are okay and
the only residual issue they'll have to
deal with is their horribly mutilated
bodies you got some Star Wars and my
Willy Wonka movie
proper young Brit would say elevator
it's a lift dear Veruca you want a
flying glass lift you must be the boy's
parents yeah dad all right that
manufactured an unnecessary Wonka
backstory still hasn't been resolved
guess we've got another 15 minutes a
fudge Mountain to wade through I had the
strangest revelation Bree there's still
time for another flashback who would
watch over them after I was gone I
realized in that moment
I must find it here hey movie will
handle the ham-handed puns over here
dammit
yes please and this movie wraps up more
cleanly and wholesome than a king
episode of growing pains like peanuts I
love peanuts only grandma Georgina's
lucid did Wonka also invent the cure for
dementia so they built an exact replica
of their whole house in the factory kind
of sense does that make
and don't give me that cheap bullshit
about how candy doesn't even have to
make sense it's their domicile
what do we got root canal and by the
looks of those x-rays it's not gonna be
pretty
[Music]
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check out and now
the audio outtakes
[Music]
you see a earmuffs niggas a bitch
whatever you want babe out Marie and
don't look at it no matter what happens
I guess this flavored chocolate coated
glue Wow
welcome to fetch Mountain would you
please give a warm welcome to John
Redcorn in big mountain fudgecake